blade Smiths welcome to the forge we've
got every type of Steel you can possibly
imagine from 1095 stock steel to 52 100
ball bearings you'll have to select at
least four of these Steels to use in a
canister Damascus bladesmiths choose
your steel choose your kin your 10
minute design window Starts Now I chose
to do a drop point recurve because it's
the first successful blade I made in my
shop for someone else so it's kind of
become personal for me he's got a lot of
white out what's he going to do with
that Ben it's got a line the inside of
his can to stop the steel from sticking
to his hand I have a pleasant surprise
of my can opening itself and I can see
the Billet inside is one piece and that
gives me great comfort as I'm getting
ready to do the quench
I'm
thanking the lord for the presence to
put a magnet on it to make sure that
it's gone non-magnetic so I know that
I'm at critical temperature
I choose to just put pressure on the
blade and hope that as it comes down to
temperature some more on its own that it
will help correct itself
my game plan is to make a clip Point
Hunter it's got a really Stout Edge to
it what's hard about a canister Damascus
is you don't know what's going on on the
inside it can be something really good
or it can be something to send you home
as I'm trying to open up this canister
I'm seeing good things on the sides and
then I get the top completely off
[Music]
uh-oh where I put those big Cube chunks
none of that's welded it's just kind of
hanging out my canister took a and
I have to start another one
doing the same process putting in my
powder except this time instead of using
those big cubes I use the small cubes I
can't blame the material but I don't
think that those big cubes helped
anything in this situation because I use
such small other pieces damn it I'm not
sure where these Sparks are coming from
but my table is on fire
I had to say the heck with it I'm moving
on so I head to the welders
I smell something burning
whoa what is going on over there just
keep welding I don't know what to do
now that the fire is under control I'm
headed back to the Ford because it's
going to take at least 10 to 15 minutes
to get this thing up to welding
temperature it looks like it welded
solid I don't see any cracks I don't see
any d-lam well I see Deke grabbing some
ball bearings I want a random pattern so
what I'm going to do is really mix it up
what else did you get over there fish
hooks bicycle chains W1 round
I like those materials because they're
all hardenable metals
normally you want to see a flat piece of
Steel and that's not what I'm seeing
an extra five minutes of letting that
white out dry will save you starting
another account it'll save you 90
minutes exactly I can see all the cracks
and all that but you really can't see
how deep the cracks go so I want to see
if it breaks
snapped in half I gotta start over from
scratch now I've got to get the canister
packed welded and in the Forge in a
hurry I've got a lot to do in a little
bit of time the second bill has fallen a
lot better than the first one it's solid
I'm gonna be kind of creative on getting
that canister off because I'm gonna
Forge it almost down to the thickness I
want it and then grind it off on the
bevels going into this heat treat
if something happens I'm done and
there's a lot of things that could go
wrong
I didn't hear any cracks or Tings that
looks pretty straight to me I won't be
comfortable until there's a fully
finished knife right here
it's going to be tight but I'm going to
put a knife on the table
three two one this first round of
competition is over blade Smith's
congratulations you've made it to round
two of this competition and now that
your blades have been tempered it's time
to turn those rough pieces of Steel into
Sleek high performance knives you'll
have three hours in which to complete
your work Additionally you must add
guards to those blades good luck your
three hour starts now I'm not great
friends with the drill press at this
point eventually I get the first hole
Lord give me another hole just one more
and then in all frankness I threw up a
prayer and said God I need this done in
three minutes and I got my second hole
done
thank you Lord
as I'm at the grinder I need it to be
sharp to go through apples and so I want
my blade to be hair shaving Sharp
the blade performs well but I don't want
to strike it on anything
my top priority right now is to get this
guard fitted
looks like Bubba is slotting that guard
yeah that's smart because get it close
with the angle grinder and then just use
the file nose to just get it real tight
that I'm going to do with the judges
hate seeing I'm going to weld it onto
the blade
I'm going with this route because it's
the fastest thing that I can do it's the
easiest thing I can do and it's more
efficient he's got two-stage rep
basically you do a spiral wrap on the
base and then you do a not over wrap on
wrap on top of that that can make a
really really nice handle this wrap is
coming out great it's probably one of my
better wraps
I've never done a canister before and I
really want to test how those welds are
going to hold up so I'm gonna beat the
hell out of it
it did phenomenal the Edge roll just a
tiny bit nothing significant so I took
it right back over to the grinder ran it
twice and it was fine
I am going to make the handle a little
bit wider right there so it just kind of
gives you that little bit of extra grip
sweet for the guard I'm going to use a
piece of three quarter inch thick brass
plate
got my guard pretty well
gotta get everything cleaned up and
glued up I take some epoxy and I'm just
kind of smearing it in the gaps there
just trying to fill them
two one blade Smith's drop your tools
stop what you're doing this second round
of competition is open
Replacements welcome to the strength
test to test the strength and durability
of your Edge as well as your overall
construction of your knives I'll be
chopping and stabbing into these paint
cans
remember this test is all about what the
cans do your knives not what your knives
do to the cans Ryan you're up first you
ready yeah man let's do this
all right
foreign
held up it's all in one piece still your
handle construction is kind of square
it's a little bit blocky and the finger
Wells and swells are set up so that my
hand is about a half an inch away from
the guard but that all being said well
done
thank you dick you're up you ready
go for it
[Music]
all right
first things first your Edge held up
really well it's still Sharp
the handle is really small it was kind
of wobbling around in my hand as I was
swinging it but all in all I like the
weight of this I like the shape of it
well done thank you
you're Obama how you feeling get after
it
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's all in one piece
but in some of the chopping this fine
Edge you put on here did take a roll
in several spots but it feels good to
swing your grind lines are nice I like
your pattern
that's a nice knife oh thank you
all right gentlemen it's time for the
sharpness test a fan favorite the Apple
slice this test is all about what your
knives do to these apples I expect to
see a good clean slice all the way
through them the dull knife my tear just
crack those apples open Brian you're up
first you ready
okay
all right Brian so down here you've got
a good sharp edge and you can see it the
first couple of apples got some good
clean slices but as we get further into
those apples you can start to see where
they've fractured and broken away and
that's because this section of the blade
right here just doesn't have much of an
edge anymore
I'd like to see it sharper but it is a
sharp knife nice and done okay all right
Deek here up next are you ready go for
it okay
come on baby
[Music]
all right Deke part of the cuts are
clean and part of the cuts the Apple
actually cracks you've got sharp
sections on this knife here and here are
sharp I will cut apples for you bet but
there are definitely some spots on this
blade that are not as sharp as others
all in all nice and done thank you Bubba
you ready get after it okay
so Bubba if you look at these apples see
how it's clean right here then cracked
clean right there and then cracked
most of those apples you can see that
they're cut maybe the first quarter or
third of the way through and then
they're just fractured out of the way so
it's still got an edge it's just not
really a sharp edge
blade Smith's the judge's deliberation
is complete they've made their final
decision the blade Smith leaving the
forge is
Bubba your blade didn't make the cut
Doug Marcotte is going to explain Baba
you put in a great effort and should be
proud of yourself however your blade
took the most damage to strength test
and as a result it suffered in the
sharpness test that's the reason we're
sending you home Bubba please surrender
your blade
[Music]
damage rolled
a little bit of a stouter edge on my
blade that's what I would have done
different
but I enjoyed every part of it it was
just the best experience I've ever come
across in this field